in vielen den letzten folgen habe ich
erfindungen angesprochen die unseren
körper stärken und verbessern
ursprünglich waren sie gedacht um
behinderungen auszugleichen oder um
krankheiten vorzubeugen
aber schnell hat die wissenschaft auch
eine möglichkeit gefunden gesunden
körpern übermenschliche kräfte zu geben
und wie zu erwarten haben viele von uns
ein problem damit unseren körper
dauerhaft zu verändern genmanipulation
am eigenen körper geht gar nicht meine
eigene hand amputieren um eine roboter
prothese zu bekommen
auf keinen fall aber was wäre wenn es
eine möglichkeit gäbe unseren körper
temporär zu verbessern ohne ihn zu
verändern
travel technology macht es möglich
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge ohr zorn
dieselbe technologie die es
beinamputierten menschen ermöglicht
wieder zugehen kann auch anders
eingesetzt werden hier wird zum beispiel
getestet wie eine art mini exoskelett
uns beim joggen unterstützen kann
die gelenke der struktur verhärten sich
bei belastung und schon so die gelenke
und knochen des joggers sobald aber kein
druck mehr ausgeübt wird ist das gelenk
des exoskelett wieder frei beweglich und
stärkt somit nicht beim laufen groß
erforscht und vorangetrieben wurden
exoskelett natürlich vom militär
soldaten können mit verschiedensten
ironman ähnlichen anzügen unglaubliche
lasten tragen kilometerweit rennen und
teilweise sogar kugeln ab während eines
der vielen beispiele in den science
fiction mal wieder die realität
inspiriert doch es geht auch in die
umgekehrte richtung startet groß und
laut kann man auch unsichtbar elektronik
am körper tragen
smart klubs also intelligente kleidung
steckt noch in den kinderschuhen hat
aber ein riesiges potenzial durch
sensoren und in den stoff eingewebte
kabel kein t shirt zum beispiel heute
schon deinen puls messen
aber das ist noch lange nicht alles
mehrere firmen arbeiten bereits daran
stoff so zu bearbeiten dass er energie
erzeugt das könnte zum beispiel über
mikro induktion passieren mit ein paar
jahren forschungen so sind sich die
wissenschaftler sicher könnte man die
technik so effizient nutzen
dass wir unser smartphone niemals an
eine steckdose stecken müssten
sobald es in deiner tasche ist sorgt
einfach dein t-shirt für die nötige
energie
die verschiedenen sensoren könnten aber
auch für mehr als nur für sportstätten
genutzt werden zum beispiel könnte dein
t-shirt erkennen wenn du einen unfall
hattest erhöhte herzfrequenz und einen
vertreter arm
sofort wird das smartphone
benachrichtigt dass dann den notarzt
ruft und das sogar wenn nur bewusstlos
bist noch besser ist aber die ama
kleidung von acht forschern aus england
diese sollen nämlich verhindern dass du
bei einem unfall überhaupt erst verletzt
wirst die smarte kleidung ist im
normalen zustand ähnlich robust wie ein
t shirt verwandelt sich aber bei
plötzlichem droht also wie zum beispiel
bei einem unfall in eine robuste hülle
die den aufprall ab dämpft und dem
träger schützt das kann den unterschied
zwischen leben und tod bedeuten
das hochgelobte und geförderte projekt
spezialisiert sich moment vor allem
darauf älteren menschen zu helfen
diese fallen häufig hin und verletzten
sich dabei schnell leider viel zu oft
auch tödlich so könnte die zukunft
unserer kleidung aussehen anstatt einer
hülle die einfach nur gut aussehen soll
werden unsere kleiner zu einer
erweiterung unseres körpers allerdings
zu einer die man auch wieder ausziehen
kann ich bin auf jeden fall sehr
gespannt was da noch alles auf uns
zukommt in der zukunft vielleicht haben
wir bald bildschirme in unserem t shirt
oder sogar ganze computer smartphones im
pullover eingewebt was man ihr was es
alles möglich würdet ihr euch solche
smart los kaufen diskutiert ist immer
mit mir unten in den kommentaren
ansonsten könnt ihr euch hier oben eines
von über 100.000 hörbüchern aussuchen
dass ihr dann gratis bekommt wenn ihr
euch einen probe account erstellt und
hier unten findet ihr wie immer meine
beiden letzten folgen von nordson vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten
mal